public sénat en partenariat avec afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le président du sénat gérard larcher est
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous à ce
rendez-vous de public sénat
je vais avoir invité avec les échos avec
radio classique et avec la sp3 grande
question monsieur le président vous
seront posées au cours de cette émission
un la transformation du pays
l'objectif affiché des manuels macron
est elle en marche
jean-francis pécresse vous interrogera
sur toutes les réformes engagées
2 comment la droite peut-elle se
réinventer question subsidiaire que vous
posera paulo rodrigues à la voix vous
qui était la bonne selon vous 3 le sénat
à doit-il être un contre-pouvoir vous
direz avec lms quelle opposition vous
voulez un carnet
mais d'abord une toute première question
d'actualité
[Musique]
un nouvel incendie criminel la nuit
dernière d'une gendarmerie en isère à
meylan précisément quatre voitures
incendiées un mois après un incendie
similaire qui avait été revendiqué par
l'extrême gauche des faits similaires se
sont également produits à limoges est ce
que ça vous inquiète
c'est un acte criminel qui doit être
traité comme un acte criminel sont
faiblesse ça me donne l'occasion de
redire
la semaine dernière j'ai visité une
compagnie de gendarmerie de rendre
hommage à l'action des gendarmes qui
depuis deux ans et demi et notamment
dans le cadre de vigipirate sion
particulièrement sollicités tout comme
les policiers et je dois dire que un
état de droit doit être solidaire de ce
qui représente cet état de droit et
assurent l'ordre
voilà c'est un acte criminel qui en plus
semble-t-il visé des familles des
gendarmes qui vivent en général dans des
casernes et je dois dire que je me sens
pleinement solidaire mais en même temps
très exigeant sur le traitement de cet
acte inqualifiable
est ce que l'état de droit incarné par
le pouvoir exécutif actuel exprime
suffisamment sa solidarité selon vous
sachant qu'on a entendu aujourd'hui
laurent wauquiez dire que gérard collomb
n'avait pas la main assez ferme
écoutez je suis entendu le ministre
d'état cet après midi sur un autre
dossier très sensible celui de marseille
je le sentiment de cette volonté est en
tous les cas je crois que c'est le
moment un peu de se serrer les coudes
face à cela et d'être à la fois pour la
défense de l'état de droit et de ceux
qui l'incarnent du gendarme
les policiers mais aussi souvent les
policiers municipaux des sapeurs
pompiers
donc vous nous dites ce soir que face à
ce genre d'événement qui se répète il
faut que la droite la gauche
et puis la majorité se serre les coudes
en fait oui et que nous soyons exigeants
en matière de réponse se serrer les
coudes ça veut pas dire n'est pas un
être en attente d'exigence qu'est ce qui
se passe du côté de l'extrême gauche
selon vous je lisais ce matin une
interview du patron de la brigade
criminelle
michel fori dans le figaro il dit
redoutez l'attrait de l'islam radical
sur des jeunes ultra violents des
nihilistes disait-il qui nourrissent une
haine de notre société est ce que ce
danger vous le percevez ce danger qui se
situe à l'extrême gauche et qui se
construit sur la haine en fait des
valeurs de la démocratie est sûre et la
haine des valeurs de la république
j'allais dire il a existé ce n'est pas
une découverte d'aujourd'hui nous
l'avons connu dans d'autres périodes de
notre histoire
au cours du 20e siècle je crois que
notre responsabilité c'est d'être sans
faiblesse sur les valeurs d'arrêt vite
que cette haine on l'a connue autrefois
mais là nous sommes dans une démocratie
apaisée et l apaiser dont elle connaît
le terrorisme et l apaiser quand on voit
qu'une fraction de ceux qui sont nés
dans nos villes nos villages ont
construit une forme de haine être inclus
dans la communauté nationale
porter une part de l'héritage et même si
on est arrivés récemment dans mary dans
l'héritage de la nation j'écrivais au
président de la république souvenez vous
il ya deux ans et demi françois hollande
près la nation un héritage emporte à
main c'est ce que je crois nous devons
réaffirmer ça veut dire être sans
faiblesse être exigeant et ne pas
baisser la garde sur les valeurs de la
république et sur ce thème là il faut
abandonner vous nous le dites tout
procès politique voire politiciens on a
compris la suite de l'épreuve de vérité
tout de suite avec jean francis pécresse
le directeur de la rédaction de radio
classique
[Musique]
bonsoir joe francis à michel bonsoir
gérard larcher est ce que la
transformation du pays promise par
emmanuel macron et bien en marche
si j'en juge que le budget est pour 2018
on est encore loin d'un budget de
transformation la réalité pour l'état
c'est un déficit budgétaire qui continue
à croître
je dis pas que c'est simple de le
réduire c'est 195 milliards que nous
allons devoir emprunter sur les marchés
financiers au long de l'année
j'allais dire heureusement qu'à la
sécurité sociale et les collectivités
territoriales pour moi dépenser parce
que nous voyons que la diminution de la
dépense publique n'est pas en marche en
même temps il ya des réformes garder les
signaux il ya des signaux qui sont aussi
des avancées les que pense à la baisse
d'un certain nombre de prélèvements
obligatoires mais comme on était record
d'europe
on a encore une marge de progrès on peut
s'arrêter parce que là il faut détailler
si on parle de la baisse effectivement
des impôts oui mais en même temps on a 5
milliards du cg on a 3 milliards 4
d'impôt de fiscalité il ya des choses je
pense à l'impôt forfaitaire sur les
revenus du capital
la baisse du taux de l'impôt sur les
sociétés la suppression partielle de
l'usf je crois qu'on aurait mieux fait
de le supprimer totalement
aulas des signaux qui sont intéressants
mais la famille sf par exemple alors
arrêtons nous quelques minutes sur ce
point là vous savez bien ce qu'on veut
ce qu'on va vous reprocher ce qu'on va
vous dire à la droite pourquoi est ce
que vous l'avez pas fait avant est ce
que c'est pas un peu trop facile de
reprocher maintenant à emmanuel macron
ne pas faire ce que feint de de faire à
moitié les choses que vous n'avez pas
fait du tout avant je reproche rien mais
je ne suis pas ce moyen ils revendaient
vous êtes dans la qui revendique ne la
transformation pour la transformation
il y avait dans l'est dans les projets
des candidats que nous soutenions la
suppression de l isf
c'est vrai que nous aurions pu le faire
avant on avait tenté de le faire
souvenez vous
c'était il ya deux décennies mais en
tous les cas je crois que le vrai sujet
par exemple on avait un engagement sur
moi 120 mille fois est claire oui sur
cinq ans ont commencé petitement 1600
donc on a une marge encore 228 1400 dans
118 400 pardonnez-moi de cette erreur de
soustraction je crois qu'il faut qu'on
soit attentif à rendre plus compétitif
aux entreprises est vraiment à maîtriser
nos dépenses publiques mais quand même
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
par rapport au quinquennat de françois
hollande la france s'est remise en
marche et remise en route qui a des
réformes qui se font kim équipe qui est
au bonheur qu'il y aura dans sa quête et
qui dit l'ont harcelé pendant cinq ans
et pardonnez moi le jeu est aujourd'hui
du quinquennat de françois hollande
et comme je respecte la fonction c'était
quand même un quinquennat pour rien pour
rien on n'aurait rien et qu'on n'apprend
rien q les je constate on avance un peu
c'est quand même parce que calé au fond
quand je dis dans mes propos le jour où
je suis réélu président du sénat qui
m'importe c'est l'état de mon pays si
mes entreprises jeudi mais en trouver
parce que je suis français les
entreprises de france vaut mieux demain
elle crée plus de richesses pour
qu'elles créent l'emploi et comment je
ne soutiendrai pas ce qui m'apparaît
être des pas dans la bonne direction
alors est ce que par exemple si on prend
le budget 2010 8 est ce que au sénat
vous êtes partisan de voter ce budget en
état ou de vous abstenir ou de voter
contre
le propre du chênet c'est de faire des
propositions nous allons avoir des vrais
débats sur une question qui n'est pas
petit et qui a été abordée aujourd'hui
dans le cadre des questions au
gouvernement
la question du logement on est sur 37
milliard 7,2 budget de l'état et quand
même pas énorme ça concerne pas
simplement le logement social mais tout
le soutien construction de logements
derrière le soutien au logement et à la
réponse aux besoins des français
et c'est une réponse qui n'est pas rien
il ya derrière entre guillemets
l'industrie du bâtiment et nous allons
faire des propositions parce que voyez
dans leur grange qui est fait
aujourd'hui uniquement par le biais de
la paix elle ne suffira pas et donc sur
ce point il faut que le gouvernement
nous écoute et nous entende
d'autant plus que abordé de manière sur
la sellette la question du logement le
loeuff social c'est mettre en péril les
collectivités territoriales qui
garantissent les emprunts qui permettent
la construction du logement social plus
de 160 milliards d'euros
sur ces 37 milliards d'euros vous voulez
faire plus d'économies que le
gouvernement n'en fait c'est pas une
question uniquement d'économie un peu
quand c'est à quoi sert quels
productivité financière nous avons des
charges on aime bien merci
j'ai proposé un président de la
république et au premier ministre
et c'est ce n'est pas secret d'état que
nous mettions autour de la table pour
essayer de dégager un consensus sur
cette question du logement pas
simplement de l'apl je pense que nous
avons un vrai défi quand on fait le
calcul c'est en fait 8 % du budget 37
milliard cette question sur la santé ou
plus précisément sur les hôpitaux vous
avez été président de la fédération
hospitalière de france
quand agnès buzyn ministre de la santé
dit il faut financer les hôpitaux
maintenant non plus à l'activité mais en
gros à la pertinence des soins en
fonction de la pertinence des soins
qu'ils pensaient ce que c'est une bonne
orientation est ce que vous la soutenez
je pense que la question de l'utilité
des soins parce que je peux utiliser des
mots que chacun peut partager et une
question qui est posée savons tous la
fédération hospitalière de france latine
n'y a pas si longtemps qu'il ya des
soins inutiles redondant que nous avons
un tiers un tiers du ministre
une vraie réforme structurelle parce
qu'au fond on a un plfss
aujourd'hui qui les lierait plus dans la
sincérité que
des annonces de madame touraine qui nous
annoncent qu'ils nous disaient le retour
à l'équilibré mais ce qui manque encore
aujourd'hui c'est la réorganisation de
la place entre la médecine de ville la
médecine hospitalière
nous avons le sujet d'absence de
praticiens sur une partie du territoire
qui oblige un recours excessif à
l'hôpital ou à la clinique
je crois que on est dans une direction
col et professionnelle relève comme une
direction positive mais au fond derrière
on n'engage pas les réformes parce que
nous avons comme seul paramètre
directives que bercy je pense qu'il faut
poser la question de la santé
globalement sur l'assurance chômage par
exemple est ce que il ya une réforme qui
est maintenant lancée avec une feuille
de route peut-être pas très clair mais
enfin en tout cas une feuille de route
est ce que vous êtes favorable ou est ce
que les droits à l'assurance chômage
soit ouvert aux professions
indépendantes est ce que c'est une bonne
piste d'abord il faut se lancer dans un
vrai dialogue social sur l'avenir de
l'assurance chômage et des là pour
assurer des revenus de remplacement
pendant la période moore n'a pas on ne
perçoit pas de revenus du travail mais
l'assurance chômage
c'est aussi
et la responsabilité du retour vers
l'emploi or aujourd'hui nous voyons bien
que ce volet manque énormément
quand même temps nous avons nous allons
tranquillement vers 40 milliards de
déficit cumulé voilà pourquoi il faut
confier au dialogue social pour savoir
non mais c'est moins lourdes et le droit
sur les si on va vers une gestion qui
continuent à être paritaires ou dans
lequel l'état intervient qui serait une
forme de tri parti alors la quatrième
année la question d'ouvrir à l'assurance
chômage aux indépendants et aux salariés
démissionnent nations indépendantes et
aux salariés démissionnaires pour voir
dans quel cadre
si c'est pour accompagner un projet de
retour vers l'emploi et bien à ce
moment-là l'assurance chômage
d'ailleurs pleinement son rôle c'est
dans ce cadre là d'accord avec un pour
gêner avec un projet alors entourent
verlan qu'est-ce que sur ce sujet de
l'assurance chômage et de la couverture
sociale est ce que quand laurent
wauquiez fustige ceux les chômeurs qui
profite de la vie et ce qu'il fait une
erreur il dit que c'est sur le conseil
de pôle emploi a même coûté ya on a
l'impression qu'on voit revenir une
droite qui utilisent des fascines la
bougie on parle de moi est une méthode
laurent wauquiez donc on en parlera dans
les mineures dans l'expérience qui m a
bien compris qui commence à dater un peu
il ya dix ans d'avoir été ministre du
travail
je crois qu'il faut bien se poser la
question quel est le rôle et la place de
l'assurance chômage qu'elle est de son
rôle dans le retour vers l'emploi
et derrière il ya d'autres questions
quelle formation tout au long de la vie
et oui quelle formation professionnelle
qui est axé sur la table le retour vers
l'emploi
voilà les vrais sujets naturellement la
lutte contre la fraude
elle est un sujet non négligeable parce
qu'il ya naturellement des fraudeurs
sont ils des légions à ce point je n'en
suis pas tout à fait persuadé mais
lutter contre la fraude est une exigence
que nous avons il a vite donc de ceux
qui réellement donkey la neige les
difficultés de la torre wauquiez de dire
ça je pense qu'il a tort il a raison il
soulignant ya 20 ans il souligne un veau
n'est pas la même vision lutter contre
la fraude je le partage
laurent wauquiez mais en même temps je
ne résume pas la question de l'assurance
chômage
à la question vous avez beaucoup parlé
du budget une question sur la taxe sur
les dividendes qui a été donc censuré
bruno le maire a dénoncé la répéter un
scandale d'état il s'en est pris aux
amateurs un scandale d'état de 10
milliards 1 ce matin sur public sénat
stéphane le foll est renvoyé et lui la
patate chaude à nicolas sarkozy on les
écoute
stéphane le foll qui considèrent est
considéré en tous les cas que en fait la
taxe sur les dividendes a été la
conséquence d'une autre taxe qui avait
été son livre écouté on peut se renvoyer
la balle
ce que je sais c'est que senna en 2016
ils ont remporté en général a souligné
la fragilité de cet axe par rapport aux
directives européennes
aujourd'hui c'est clair il va falloir
qu'on trouve une solution de 10
milliards cette solution il va falloir
que nous en parlions avec gouvernement
parce que nous sommes des gens qui
assumons nos responsabilités et au sénat
nous devrons être de ceux qui
contribuent à la réflexion sur la
solution se renvoyer savoir si c'est
nicolas sarkozy
moi je retiens une seule chose c'était
dans le projet de françois hollande nous
ramène à la date 2012 au projet de
françois hollande nous l'avions mis en
garde
nous n'avons pas été écoutés et on en
voit les conséquences n'ont
manifestement le gouvernement veut faire
un texte budgétaire
voilà spécial particulier à la fin
d'année ce qu'on appelle un collectif
budgétaire et du projet de loi de
finances rectificative doit de finances
rectificative pour être pardonné mois
mais est ce que c est ce que c est ce
que c'est une voie là est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça si tu écoutes et
on va voir le projet tel qu'il est la
bonne formule gouvernement mort n'a
informé
est ce qu'il faut aller vite le
gouvernement d'informer je vais voir
avec le rapporteur général
le président de la commission des
finances là aussi il faut qu'on pense
quel est l'intérêt supérieur de notre
pays est ce que c'est de se renvoyer le
ballon de rugby pour savoir si c'était
en 1995 que tout ça mais là c'est
l'heure des décisions et du conférencier
nationalement
jean cela et il faut qu'on apporte des
réponses qui ne conduisent pas un
nouveau déséquilibre budgétaire dans
notre pays ok faut aller vite
2 qu'il faut aller vite clair mais ça
vous démontre que ces taxes qu'on
invente sur des coins de table ou sur
des pulsions pour faire plaisir à une
clientèle par rapport à une autre
c'est une mauvaise manière de faire de
la politique si j'ai un reproche à faire
dans le projet de françois hollande
c'est que ce type de proposition elle
été lancée comme un élément un peu
contre la finance contre les entreprises
y envoient le résultat deux dernières
questions dernière question qu'est-ce
que vous inspirent les propos d emmanuel
macron devant le président égyptien si
sydney qui émanait de mâcon disant qu'il
n'avait pas de leçon à donner en matière
de droits de l'homme au président
égyptien savez j'ai hier soir reçu le
président el sissi et notre rencontre a
duré longtemps
j'ai eu un entretien en tête à tête sur
un certain nombre de sujets dont les
sujets des droits de l'homme et je
garderai pour moi parce que l'intérêt
des gens n'importe plus que les annonces
mais je pense que le président de la
république a eu raison
l'egypte est confrontée comme toute la
région à un extraordinaire défi
terroristes et nous avons besoin d'une
égypte qui lutte contre le terrorisme et
les siens l'osé mesure est conforme
donner des leçons on parle aussi de la
répression des homosexuels qui n'ont pas
grand chose à voir a priori je garderai
pour moi les roriz échanges que j'ai eus
avec le président el sissi parce que je
suis à très attaché au bras de l'homme
mais en même temps 1200 km de frontière
avec la libye où nous savons que les
djihadistes qui sont chassés d'irak et
de syrie ont tendance à vouloir
s'installer
nous avons besoin d'une égypte qui est
aux contreforts de la lutte contre le
terrorisme
en même temps d'une égypte qui est en
train de procéder à un ajustement
économique qui est douloureux
les signes du redémarrage économique et
et sont là
avant m 2 des donneurs de leçons soyez
les gens qui est don mais qui aidons
aussi avec nos valeurs et j'ai évoqué
devant lui le débat que nous avons eu
sur la loi pierrot riche équilibre entre
sécurité et liberté
merci jean francis astier de l'épreuve
de vérité avec paul aubry ya maintenant
de l' agence france-presse
l'épreuve de vérité avec la fp
bonsoir paul est bienvenu c'est votre
première participation à l'épreuve de
vérité
votre question à gérard larcher soir
gérard larcher comment la droite
peut-elle se réinventer se réinventer
pour la droite que le centre moi je
pense que c'est l'ensemble des familles
politiques qu'il incarne d'abord dans le
constat de notre situation
voilà pourquoi personne n'en parle je
suis avec attention les conclusions des
ateliers de la refondation
près de cinquante mille militants et
sympathisants de la famille et l'air
auront participé à ces ateliers de leurs
fondations
et puisque la campagne électorale
interne à la famille des républicains
s'engage
je crois qu'on ne peut pas passer par
pertes et profits le sentiment de
plaisir de nos compagnons oui c'est une
dérive gaulliste chez moi mais c'est
ainsi en tous les cas de ceux avec
lesquels je partage
l'appartenance aux républicains et puis
à partir de ça il ya un certain nombre
de principes qui sont posées quelle est
notre vision de la liberté de la
responsabilité
quel est notre vision du rôle et de la
place de l'état et de l'exécutif par
rapport à la décentralisation à la vie
des territoires
comment à l'intérieur d'un mouvement ou
des mouvements
nous respectons les sensibilités comment
nous avons des barrières hermétique
avant par les catalans de contre-valeur
on va on va en parler mais vous dites
moi ça fait particulièrement profonde et
on se refonde pas dans l'osmose avec des
valeurs qui sont contraires au doute
est-ce qu'on se confondent en étant plus
à droite est ce qu'elle doit se
déportait à droite et encore plus à des
jolies dames identité du jeu à droite il
ya des gens qui comme moi sont plutôt
engagée autour du gaullisme ya des
jaloux tango qui sont moins en moins à
l'aise
est ce que vous vous êtes à l'aise sens
à l'aise elle a conditionné le soin
respecter un certain nombre de principes
et comme je vais voir les trois
candidats dans les jours qui viennent je
ne signais pour personne mais je
souhaite l'unité de ma famille
aromatique notre joie est ouvert
stade c'est pas mon choix non mais
extrêmement on nous propose quel respect
des sensibilités
comment fonctionne la démocratie comment
on reconstruit un vrai projet à proposer
à nos concitoyens parce que si c'est un
projet entre nous pardonnez moi ou les
chorales de personnalités ça n'a aucun
intérêt
qu'est ce que nous proposons au pays je
crois qu'on aille responsable en a déjà
des responsabilités qui me dit fier
aussi de la proche d'un certain nombre
de nos amis qui nous ont quittés je
crois que entre l'extrême gauche et
l'extrême droite et continue à y avoir à
l'espace pour des partis politique
d'alternance qui se situe certains à
gauche d'autres centre et à droite
alors si on parle des trois candidats
aujourd'hui à la haute autorité des
républicains a annoncé les trois
candidats officiels ces mails de calan
florence portelli et et laurent wauquiez
grandvaux qui est présenté comme favori
c'est par un secret j'ai connu des
favoris ouais alors pas mourir il n'est
pas favori pour vous ils paradent
aurions été bien sûr il est présenté
comme tel
quand j'étais petit j'ai perdu des
favoris je fais allusion à françois fil
des événements au plus peut-il perdre
laurent wauquiez ne sais pas mais en
tous les cas je sais je souhaite que les
trois candidats suscitent un vrai débat
partant de nos ateliers de la fondation
partant aussi de ce qu'ils ressentent
on voit bien chez laurent wauquiez que
le sentiment d'appartenance à une
communauté nationale c'est quelque chose
de fort mais aussi dans la clarté
monsieur bilan n'appartient pas pour moi
aux valeurs qui sont les miennes alors
méfiance et le président de sens commun
c'est c'est bien ça surprenant c'est
l'émanation des manifs pour tous au sein
des républicains certains chez les
républicains demandent à ce que monsieur
biya en soient exclues ou ce que la
convention qui vit sens commun aux
républicains soient dénoncés vous quelle
est votre position par rapport à cette
question moi il s'est séparé totalement
la famille politique je ne parle pas de
chance coma qui n'est pas vraiment ma
tasse de thé
je suis un homme trop engagé dans la
laïcité même si j'ai des convictions
elle se sent se cognera personnel que
tout le monde connaît mais
sens commun c'est autre chose que son
président je n'ai pas entendu de la part
de sens commun en tant que tel en
permanence donc en ont en commun non non
on n'aurait pas avoir un double
appartenance
dès qu'on a franchi cette barrière qui
nous rapprocherait de l'ex-femme avec
l'idée d'envisager un dialogue avec nos
dialogues m'arriver maréchal le pen
c'est ça quand on est chez wauquiez hier
c'était à mon dieu la nappe ou comme
lors de leur dernier type de phrase
assez étonnant que la première a été
cité tout à l'heure dans l'émission
concernant les chômeurs alors laurent
wauquiez estime que pôle emploi conseils
aux chômeurs n'ont pas de chercher un
emploi mais de profiter de la vie fin de
citation
vienne deuxième citation jeu laurent
wauquiez qui dit hier nacre on est prêt
à ce que pour réussir la france se renie
nous pensons que la france doit se
retrouver
est-ce que vous pensez que macron est
prêt à ce que la france se renier et
d'une manière générale ces deux phrases
extrêmement droitière est ce qu'elle
vous conviennent est ce que c'est la
droite que je vous donne en moi j'ai
envie envie que la france se retrouve
nous évoquions tout à l'heure un certain
nombre
et notamment de jeunes qui avaient le
sentiment pu appartenir ne pas
appartenir à la communauté nationale
moi j'ai envie que la france se retrouve
autour de ces valeurs dans sa diversité
dans son héritage mais son héritage
c'est pas simplement un héritage
religieux c'est beaucoup de choses qui
ont construit la france dans son
histoire
moi j'ai une vision positive de la
france
j'ai une vision autour de ce qu'il a
construit tout au long des siècles et
cette france au long des siècles
c'est vraiment celle que de gaulle voyez
quoi aux fresques des murs leurs biens
sur la fresque du mur d'aujourd'hui il
n'ya pas la fresque des murs de 1935 ou
ou de 1958
mais ce serait ce que des murs c'est
comment nous sommes une communauté au
sein de leurs dans notre diversité
participant au projet européen est
important au monde
un certain nombre de valeurs y compris à
lui dire quand j'entends le président
entre sommes parlé d' america first
moi je me dis d'abord democracy first
humanisme force et je n'ai pas le
sentiment pour autant de ne pas être
profondément français
on va écouter laurent wauquiez qui a
parlé de l'europe hier soir à mandelieu
lors d'un meeting donc illac s'est
déclarée européen mais il a critiqué
également tout de suite après on écoute
puis au moment des européennes les gens
j'ai ramené ma foi dans l'europe
mais une autre puissance une europe qui
défend ses frontières
une europe qui portent de grands projets
pour notre
une europe qui travaille pour
l'intégration de nos universités et de
la recherche pas une europe passoire pas
une europe qui assistent passive à des
vagues migratoires au delà de la raison
paul quelle est la différence gérard
larcher entre grands wauquiez et marine
le pen sur sur l'europe est ce que une
europe puissante paris de pub avait
totalement la verte puisque et voulait
torpiller l'euro une europe puissante si
une europe qui s'engagent y compris en
matière de défense à avoir un projet
partagé une europe de projets c'est
vraiment une europe qui se fixé un
certain nombre d'objectifs si on parle
de politique agricole commune est ce que
le projet ce n'est pas d'être un des
acteurs de entre guillemets de larmes
verte dans le monde mais en même temps
d'une approche écologique du monde
une europe dans lequel les universités
la recherche se mettant en commun c'est
vraiment indécis on arrive au dernier
rang qui évoquent louis et la raison
frontex pour que ça fonctionne mieux
parce que ça on a regardé si nous
voulons rester d'été y des des endroits
où la notion de l'accueil de l'asie et
du sens nous devons en même temps
traiter de la question migratoire
voilà pourquoi je suis pour les accords
de réadmission voilà pourquoi je suis
peau norov forcément de frontex et en
même temps c'est protéger des
populations qui aujourd'hui connaissent
par les guerres ethniques par les
guerres religieuses par l'extraordinaire
sécheresse une déstabilisation etc
j'allais lire sur la misère de l'afrique
le qu'on construit les vagues
migratoires et ses vagues migratoires
moi j'ai un autre projet pour l'afrique
et ça ça peut être un grand projet de
leurs emprunts et voilà pourquoi aucun
de ces mots ne me choquent ne me choque
c'est la proche de ces mots savez j'ai
été à l'amp et 12 je vais vous dire
quand vous revenez de lampedusa les
hommes et les femmes que vous voyez
lampedusa ils sont comme vous et comme
moi sauf qu'ils sont dans le malheur et
ces hommes et ces femmes qui sont dans
le malheur
notre problème aujourd'hui c'est de
faire qui ne sera pas dans la situation
d'avoir été exploités comme ils l'ont
été dans cette traversée qui est une
forme de calvaire incroyable du niger et
surtout de la libye on a des prises de
position tout à l'heure on parie la
droite et du centre
l'actualité du début de semaine chez les
républicains s'étaient le psychodrame
avec les constructif qui ne sont
toujours pas exclue il n'y a pas eu de
quorum
réunis mardi pour pour les exclure ou
non du reste alors il y aura une énième
réunion mardi prochain
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire ces
épisodes sont fins et finalement on
parle de juridique
en fait il faut acter une séparation
politique est ce que c'est la solution
excellent mais il faut acter vous
pourrez prendre deux minutes c'est pas
un drame
une séparation politique on le vit dans
d'autres choses mais vous savez en
politique seuls les actes comptent
gérald arbanats par exemple s'est
présenté sur une liste de la république
en marche contre la liste centriste aux
sénatoriales à liszt et la liste des
républicains le premier ministre j'aime
bien que je me suis introduit cet après
midi il sous quel candidat quelques bons
concurrents eux dans les yvelines
alors ma position quand les choses vont
dans le bon sens ça va parce qu'on les
soutienne e l'exclusion si c'est la
solution juridique mais en fait c'est
acté une séparation comme je considère
que monsieur bilan pour des raisons sans
doute encore plus grave parce qu'elles
touchent à des valeurs fondamentales
c'est totalement séparée de notre
famille politique puis je voudrais dire
un mot parce qu'on a beaucoup parlé de
laurent wauquiez des élections à
l'intérieur de l air et puis on a parlé
du nouveau monde
je vois que tous les cas le vieux monde
est revenu bien vite ce questionnaire
est au tour désigné par le président de
la république
on va même nommé les 30 membres qui vont
l'entourer
c'est quand même une conception du
nouveau monde qui m'étonne un peu je
préfère les processus plus démocratique
à l'intérieur des formations politiques
les dans la façon de présider la france
est ce que
c'est le retour à l'ancien monde selon
vous est-ce que c'est des méthodes
nouvelles couches de gouvernance vous
savez que ça veut dire un monde entre le
monde je les dis dans mon propos le 2
octobre était comme passé en 80 de
l'ombre à la lumière
on a vu le résultat alors on a un
sondage opinionway comme chaque semaine
pour cette émission gérard larcher une
question porte justement sur l'exclusion
d'edouard philippe et gérald darmanin et
sébastien lecornu dont qui ont rejoint
gouvernement les sympathisants et l'air
disent oui à ce départ cette exclusion à
55%
ils sont donc majoritaires n'aura 42%
mais sur l'ensemble des français c'est
plus équilibré oui 48% non 49% donc
l'opinion est quand même partagé oui
mais je crois que un mouvement politique
doit aussi de avoir de la clarté
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit c'est plutôt
un constat de séparation c'est un choix
différent c'est un choix que je respecte
c'est pas mon choix mais c'est pour ça
que je pense que la décision par exemple
qui a été prise par le ministre de
l'économie est une bonne idée rejoindre
en mars il a rejoint où nous savons tous
un certain nombre prépare un nouveau
mouvement politique
aura-t-il l'imprimatur où ce même c'est
autre chose c'est ce qu'elle dit résumé
rester en une dernière question à ses
filiales et rapidement alors là on est à
une question sur le harcèlement a
simplement c'est la question dont tout
le monde parle actuellement est ce que
vous en tant que président du sénat on
vous a rapporté des faits ce cousin nain
pression c'est quelque chose qui existe
au sénat tout simplement nous avons
travaillé
vous pourriez reprendre des bureaux
depuis six mois nous allons nous avons
mis en place une procédure de prévention
du harcèlement qu'il soit moral ou
qu'ils soient sexuelles et c'est quelque
chose d'important si quelque chose de
sale et dire qu'on doit considérer si
j'ai à connaître de fait je dois
utiliser l'article 40 du code de
procédure pénale mais qui devront se
procurer attention à n'être que dans des
tonnes et d'étangs d'émotion voilà
pourquoi j'ai souhaité que nous ayons
une véritable attitude et une conduite
de
prévention d'information et en même
temps si nécessaire de répression
ségalant à la justice donc merci
beaucoup paul dernière partie de
l'épreuve de vérité tout de suite avec
michaël szames s de public sénat
[Musique]
bonsoir michael un saint michel roussin
gérard larcher bonsoir question
évidemment on va s'attacher cette fois
au sénat le sénat peut-il être un
contre-pouvoir à emmanuel macron au
génie du sénat n'était pas un anti
pouvoir
par nature est ce qu'ils les
contre-pouvoirs je crois que c'est
indispensable en démocratie d'avoir des
contre-pouvoirs et donc nous avons une
responsabilité
ces repas simple faire comprendre à nos
compatriotes mais à jason d'un justement
oui je vais vous donner la question tout
de suite opinionway a posé des questions
pour l'épreuve de vérité le sénat
peut-il jouer le rôle de contre-pouvoir
face à la majorité des macros à
l'assemblée eh bien oui 44 % non 54%
donc il ya une majorité qui pense que
vous ne pouvez pas jouer ce rôle
by cc oui c'est qu'ils ne connaissent
pas le pouvoir constitutionnel notamment
du sénat où nos pouvoirs sont égaux
c'est qu'ils ignorent la capacité de 60
sénateurs à saisir le conseil
constitutionnel
c'est qu'ils ignorent que y compris sous
les gouvernements de manuel valls
nous avons voté amendé modifié mais
converger dans 70% des textes nous
sommes donc réellement un contre-pouvoir
et les faits le montre donc je crois que
notre responsabilité c'est pour ça que
je dis ne sommes pas un anti pouvoir
ce qui va dans le sens de l'intérêt du
pays
je le dirai ça n'a pas commencé avec
gérard larcher c'était bien avant c'est
génétique au sénat
ma formule c'est on dit jamais non par
dogmatisme et jamais oui par s'arrêter
je viendrai notamment sur les réformes
institutionnelles mais avant cela
vous a dit que ce n'était pas forcément
un contre-pouvoir est ce que ça sera un
laboratoire pour 2022 en tous les cas
sur un certain nombre de sujets je vais
évoquer tout à l'heure la question du
logement
je crois que ça peut être un lieu où on
imagine des politiques nouvelles et pas
simplement des politiques du temps où on
fait le projet de loi de finances
c'est vrai en matière de logement sévit
c'est vrai en matière d'équilibré du
territoire
c'est vrai en matière notamment de
construction européenne je pense à la
subsidiarité et rôles spécifiques du
sénat sur un certain nombre de sujets
vous nous sommes les gardiens vigilants
la subsidiarité mais aussi de projets
partagés notamment pour préparer la
politique agricole commune futur vous
avez lancé il ya trois ans un certain
nombre de réformes pour moderniser
l'institution est ce qu'il faut
continuer est ce qu'il faut de nouvelles
réformes
vous savez la réforme ça ne s'arrête pas
un jour et elle doit être permanente
j'ai proposé j'ai réuni ce matin pour la
première fois le bureau du sénat nous
devons notamment réformer la manière
dont nous faisons la loi je pense que
nous faisons trop de lois des doigts
trop longue trop bavarde qui sont de
moins en moins comprise par nos
concitoyens
quand une loi n'est pas partagée dans
une démocratie
quelque part elle devient fragile elle
doit être comprise et donc réformer
notre manière de légiférer ça fait
partie des projets que nous portons eux
ici eux au sénat il ya des règles
françois de rugy qui lui aussi
entreprend en ce moment de nombreuses
réformes 7 notamment qui sont sur un
chantier pour les mois à venir
je pense que le chantier le plus
important c'est la manière dont on
construit et dont on fait la loi
après yann fonctionnement de chacune de
nous a semblé j'ai conduit depuis trois
ans des réformes
j'ai vu hier pour les anciens présidents
qu'ils sont ralliés une réforme que j'ai
conduite ya neuf ans donc
mais la chose la plus importante notre
rôle faire la loi
contrôler le gouvernement et être des
acteurs de propositions pour l'avenir si
ça le rôle d'une assemblée et j'ai le
désir vraiment de trouver entre les
français leur parlement une nouvelle
compréhension parce qu'on le voit est
compris dans ce sondage
même si les choses se sont améliorées
quand on suit depuis un certain nombre
d'années
il ya encore une césure entre le
parlement et nos compatriotes et notre
rôle en à l'ancien terrain en partageant
en expliquant en ayant de la visibilité
vous contribuez à la visibilité à la
meilleure compréhension du rôle et de la
place du parlement
voilà pourquoi les chaînes
parlementaires sont si importantes à mes
yeux je crois que on peut retrouver les
bases d'une démocratie plus apaisée et
qui fait plus confiance en mes
défenseurs des territoires également
c'est ce que vous souhaitez edouard
philippe le premier ministre a fait une
lettre aux élus que vous avez
certainement lu
il se veut plutôt rassurant sur la taxe
d'habitation compenser à l'euro près
notamment la baisse des dotations et a
pas de baisse dit-il contrats aidés
maintenue notamment dans les secteurs
cruciaux bref rassuré monsieur larcher
non celle inverse de ce qui s'est passé
en outre et en a1gp j'espère que on
retrouve ainsi ce que j'ai souhaité et
dont je ce dont je me suis entretenu et
avec le président de la république et
avec le premier ministre
retrouver la confiance et le respect
mutuel on a quand même eu trois épisodes
difficiles récemment la relation avec
les régions de craquer la pente klaxons
et des territoires des relations
difficiles avec les départements sont
des sujets essentiels savez la question
des mineurs isolés
c'est pas une petite question c'est la
question de la protection de nos forces
qui est posée et des relations sur l'eau
et l'assainissement parce que le texte
venait du sénat tout ça me semble des
approches où il est nécessaire de
retrouver la confiance en moi je me
réjouis que on puisse retrouver
j'allais dire une part de chemin je
ferai donc un dialogue rebours
des propositions premier ministre pour
la participation conseil national des
territoires scoop
oui je réserve j'irai moi-même au
conseil national des territoires et
d'autres scoop peut-être que vous pouvez
nous livrer sur celui-là territoire
c'est celui là le lieu peut-être du
conseil national territory
je souhaite qu'ils aient placé tahrir
tant il a commencé au sénat
c'était un symbole et j'ai remercié le
président de la république d'avoir porté
symbole parce que c'est l'article 24 de
la constitution
il est toujours bon donnant la
construire on a envie d'autres scoop
encore si on n'a plus beaucoup de temps
notamment sur vos discussions avec le
verrons l'entrée le chef de l'état le 14
octobre dernier selon les informations
constitutionnel et sur la faune
constitutionnel
il vous a proposé un accord sur ces
réformes et c'est exact nous avons
débattu de la réforme institutionnelle
trois minutes
euh pardon nous reste trois minutes est
ce que cette exacte qui vous a formulé
un accord de principe à mettre sur la
table
nous nous sommes dit qu'il fallait qu'on
trouve des points de convergence et moi
je suis ouvert
je les dis déjà publiquement et je dois
dire que le dialogue est ouvert avec le
président de la république fin nez avec
le président du sénat mais moi derrière
j'ai les sénateurs et et sénateurs c'est
pas moi qui les désignent je vous
rappelle et il faudra trouver ses points
d'équilibré il ya les points d'
équilibre institutionnel sur des sujets
anciens déjà conseil supérieur de la
magistrature
senna s'est déjà prononcée ça c'est pas
une ligne rouge
parlons des lignes rouges les housses et
des vignes de limite à ce péril des
lignes blanches attire t avec lequel on
peut se retrouver vite à sion du nombre
de mandats dans le temps
c'est non à sauf si sauf rien généré
c'est le choix démocratique réduction
des nombres des parlementaires dans les
territoires et ça n'est pas ce n'est pas
ce en sus trip tôt quelque chose qui
relève de la constitution ce qui relève
de la constitution c'est le rôle du
sénat dans la représentation du
territoire et notamment pour sortir de
l'étau du seul critère démographique et
je le dis parce que je suis l'élu d'un
département
richer démographie il est important que
le cdh a parce que
avoir deux chambres c'est pas avoir des
champs qui automatiquement se
ressemblent ii y compris dans la nature
de la représentation
l'assemblée nationale représente en
direct les citoyens le peuple nous
représentons les territoires et les
citoyens au travers du suffrage
universel indirect
voilà des points sur lequel nous pouvons
nous retrouver ce que j'ai retenu de
notre échange avec le président de la
république que c'était l'année de change
positif qui nous permettait d'avancer
dira donc un nouvelle rencontre bien sûr
je sortirai un fonctionnement en
fonctionnement des institutions
je suis pas camper dans un coin et je
considère que le président un ample et
légitime à l'esj est qu'il n'est pas
légitime
henin qui s'inquiètent non il est
légitime donc il est légitime que sa
légitimité est la mienne eh bien nous
dialoguions c'est ma conception de la
démocratie nous dit ce soir que sur les
grandes réformes constitutionnelle
envisagée par le chef de l'état nous
allons poursuivre le dise que vous
pouvez comprendre le cheveu l'état et
nuit a commencé à vous comprendre je
crois a donc le canada est le croit
benefit et pouvons nous comprendre
sur un certain nombre de points j'espère
que nous irons au bout
en tous les cas ça n'est pas une espèce
de coup de part et d'autre ça que je
veux vous dire d'accord je peux
comprendre et je pense que certaines
évolutions savez j'ai souvent dire
attention touche pas la constitution
tous les matins si on le fait on le
mesure bien ça n'est pas un coup toucher
à la constitution
ça doit être strictement nécessaires et
permettre à notre pays de mieux
fonctionner à notre démocratie d'être
renforcée et aux citoyens d'avoir
confiance dans la décision politique qui
est prise on en gagnera avec doigté et
vous formez un couple avec le chef de
l'état manifestement sur cette question
merci beaucoup
gérard larcher d'avoir été avec nous
cette semaine merci michael à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]